maxime is trying to keep his children
distracted from the horrors of their
home
two weeks ago they heard an air raid
siren and ran down to the basement it
was lucky they did
this is what's left of their apartment
building
there was a huge explosion everyone was
terrified he says adding his godmother
and two of their friends were killed
the family lives in harkev ukraine's
second largest city has endured the
second most russian attacks next only to
mariupol the city is hit by rockets and
artillery dozens of times each day more
than 10 percent of the buildings have
been destroyed homes schools and
shopping plazas
it's very scary we spend most of the
time hiding in our basement this couple
says the city says a third of its one
and a half million residents have fled
many who've stayed have moved
underground
victoria has spent three weeks living in
the subway with her husband daughters
and cats after their home was destroyed
why is russia doing this she asks why
hurt children why hurt old people why do
we suffer many of her extended family
members live in russia the city is
located just 40 kilometers from the
russian border and has long enjoyed
close ties with moscow
we are all russian speakers in this area
and for some reason we're shelled the
most she says we met the city's mayor in
a secret location he says his residents
have seen the hardships in the
russian-controlled regions of donetsk
and luhansk
the russians mistake was that they
thought if 90 percent of the city speaks
russian then we will greet them with
flowers he says they did not realize
that the city of harkiv was is and will
be ukrainian one of the key pretexts of
russia's invasion of ukraine was to
protect
russian-speaking communities like this
one well this is what vladimir putin's
protection looks like this was an
apartment building that was shelled just
recently and as you can see that rubble
is still everywhere
the belongings of family members here
who were killed in this explosion
children's toys stuffed animals clothes
books
it is absolutely horrific
a military press officer took global
news for a tour of the aftermath we were
instructed to follow his car and were
far from the front line when we heard
gunfire
warning shots fired into the air by
ukrainian soldiers whom it turned out
hadn't been told by their colleague that
we were coming
yet another example of a city on edge
after nearly five weeks of relentless
attacks and yet many residents including
maxim's family refused to leave
we were born here and we will die here
he says today the bombing is here
tomorrow it's somewhere else we will not
run away from our homeland we will not
give up this city
that's a microphone his playful
five-year-old daughter jenna testing out
our microphone seemed blissfully unaware
of the evidence all around them that in
this war no target is off limits
then another air raid siren and the
family heads for shelter once again
jeff semple global news arkiv ukraine